good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight yesterday morning joe
biden's secretary of state a man called
tony blinken went on to the sunday show
over at cbs news to announce a new
policy toward russia
going forward lincoln explained the bide
administration will use poland as a
cutout to send fighter jets to the
government of ukraine those jets will be
used to fight the russian military
blinken announced this in a calm even
tone that suggested this was
conventional procedure business as usual
nothing to worry about just on their
weekend the state department
but in fact it's not typical it's a very
big step it could turn out to be a pivot
point in history and for that reason we
want to show you the entire exchange
here it is
if for instance the polish government a
nato member wants to send fighter jets
does that get a green light from the us
are you afraid that that will escalate
tension
no that that that gets a green light in
fact we're talking uh with our polish
friends right now about what we might be
able to do to backfill
their needs if in fact they choose to
provide these fighter jets to to the
ukrainians uh what could we do how can
we help to make sure that
they get something to backfill the
planes that they're handing over to to
the ukrainians
are you afraid that will escalate
tension asks the script reader because
even a cbs news anchor knows that
sending fighter jets to a war usually
does that
no replies tony blink and that gets a
green light
it's a remarkable exchange what are we
watching here apart from a conversation
between two incredibly shallow people
who have limited contact with reality
what we're watching is the beginning of
a war between the united states and
russia
if that sounds jarring what else would
you call it now you may support
everything that tony blinken just said
maybe you do support it but let's not
lie about what's happening let's be as
honest and clear-eyed as we can be
especially now because it matters
the bi-administration just inserted
itself with force into the middle of a
hot war between two foreign powers
that means the united states is now an
active participant in a war we are at
war with russia
whether or not that war has been
officially declared whether or not
congress has authorized that war all of
that is irrelevant
that war is happening right now as we
watch
why is no one in washington saying
anything about this
because they support it they always have
almost five years ago way back in 2017
congressman eric swalwell of california
came on this show for another russia
gate debate one of many he came to let
us know how vladimir putin had gotten
donald trump elected president it was
all as stupid as you remember it until
the end of the interview when swallow
said something odd and interesting
swallow explained that because putin had
installed donald trump secretly in the
white house the united states should now
quote
do everything we can to expand nato's
role in other words we should let
ukraine join nato
that's odd
why would he say that why would a policy
so seemingly obscure nato ukraine what
why would that be a priority for some
forgettable congressman from the east
bay
well simple because getting ukraine to
join nato was the key to inciting war
with russia we didn't get it at the time
now it's obvious vladimir putin just
invaded ukraine because he didn't want
ukraine to join nato putin certainly had
other motives as well people always do
have multiple motives but that's the
main reason russia invaded the russians
don't want american missiles on their
border they don't want a hostile
government next door
now that's true whether you're allowed
to say it in public right now or not it
has been true for a long time a lot has
been written about this over many years
by serious people no one who knows
anything and is honest will tell you
putin invaded ukraine simply because he
is evil putin may be evil he certainly
seems to be but he also has strategic
motives in doing that whether or not you
agree with those motives that's
irrelevant those are the facts so with
those facts in mind the bid
administration's behavior in the days
before the ukraine invasion tells you a
lot about what motivated them
with russian troops massed by the
thousands on the ukrainian border joe
biden sent kamala harris the least
capable diplomat in washington to
explain america's policy to european
heads of state
at a public press event at the munich
security conference kamala harris
encouraged ukraine to become a member of
nato quote i appreciate and admire
president zielenski's desire to join
nato
message
up yours vladimir putin go ahead and
invade ukraine and of course vladimir
putin did that just days later
so the invasion was no surprise to the
biden administration they knew that
would happen that was the point of the
exercise
we watched all this happen we missed it
how
honestly because it was insane
and therefore very hard to take
seriously why in the world would the
united states intentionally seek war
with russia
how could we possibly benefit from that
war
we still don't know the answer to that
question but it is obvious that
permanent washington has been fixated on
war with russia for a very long time a
couple of years ago you may remember
we'd forgotten
they impeached a sitting president why
for threatening to withhold military aid
to president zielenski of ukraine
failing to back a proxy war in ukraine
was the one thing donald trump was not
allowed to do as president again they
impeached him for it
and no one said much about it even in
his own party because of course they
supported war with russia too maybe even
more than the democrats did
as far back as 2016 lindsey graham of
south carolina hysterical little lindsey
graham was jumping around acting out his
war fantasies in front of foreign
soldiers in ukraine if we saw this tape
at the time we don't remember seeing it
back in 2016 ukraine seemed like a far
away place we should have paid more
attention here it is
your fight is our fight
2017 will be the year of offense
all of us will go back to washington
and we will push the case against russia
it is time for them to pay a heavier
price
your fight is our fight that's a very
strange thing for an american lawmaker
to say to a foreign military
why would the ukrainian government's
fight in 2016 possibly be our fight on
what grounds is it our fight what does
that even mean we don't know and yet now
it is demonstrably true
ukraine's fight is our fight ukraine's
war is our war it's here but most
americans did not see that coming yet
permanent washington certainly did
permanent washington understood that the
second vladimir putin's forces rolled
across the border into ukraine we would
inevitably be on a course toward war
with russia they knew
here's the president of the august
council on foreign relations on the day
of the invasion
we need now a
necessity to his war of choice and
there's got to be to raise the economic
costs at home to raise the military
costs on the ground i hate to be so
blunt but he you know the most
vulnerable thing that
that putin's vulnerable to is dead
russian soldiers so we have to make sure
ukraine has the means to
to resist
dead russian soldiers at the time that
seemed a little bellicose right out of
the gate it just happened maybe there's
some way to de-escalate this the
invasion's terrible
but isn't america's role as steward of
the west to make things better
wouldn't a prompt russian withdrawal
from ukraine be the wisest course for
everyone including and especially the
ukrainians on whose behalf we claim to
speak but whose country would be leveled
by a protracted war
you would think so but that's not what
anyone in washington wanted they wanted
a war and now they have one
so where's this going that's the
question for the rest of us who had no
role in making these
decisions well it's worrisome you should
keep in mind that the us government is
currently run by the same people who
plan the afghanistan withdrawal the ones
who tank the u.s dollar
the people who run baltimore the ones
who tried to send crack pipes to junkies
these are people with a long history of
destroying things and no history at all
of building anything
so a lot could go wrong
they tell us that vladimir putin is
unbalanced we'll take that at face value
we know that putin has thousands of
nuclear weapons putin has said that if
he is pushed he will use nuclear weapons
could be wise to believe him
harry kazianis does believe him kazianis
is a foreign policy analyst in
washington like a lot of people in his
business he regularly participates in
government-sponsored war games these are
designed to map out what would happen if
various countries fell into conflict
with one another
a couple of years ago not long ago at
all cazianos participated in a war game
predicated on a war with russia
he wrote about this the other day in the
federalist quote
in the course of what we call the
nato-russia war of 2019 we estimated
one billion people died one billion and
if we aren't careful what happened in a
simulation could happen if a nato russia
war erupts over ukraine
that war is just erupted
the fact that no one in charge seems to
worry about where this could go should
concern you quite a bit
but nuclear war is not the only risk the
economic consequences of this were
already profound they're history
changing actually and if you don't
believe it check out commodity prices
they're out of control
wheat is up nearly 60 percent over last
year that's the highest price ever
recorded for wheat
not good news if you plan to eat
and it won't get better russia is one of
the largest fertilizer producers in the
world so for example a ton of urea
fertilizer that cost american farmers
265 dollars per ton last january now
goes for
846 dollars this year and thanks to
sanctions that number will get much
higher no one who farms has ever seen
anything like this you probably don't
farm but you do buy groceries it'll be
obvious to you soon in fact thanks to
biden's foreign policy everything you
buy is shooting up in price and
shockingly fast gasoline is now higher
than it's ever been in the history of
gasoline
in los angeles it is selling for seven
dollars and 29 cents a gallon
so if you make under a hundred grand a
year and most people in this country do
that qualifies as a crisis for you
but for the people in charge it's not
high enough they'd like to make it worse
their latest idea that a lot of people
seem to be buying is that we have a
moral obligation somehow to stop buying
russian oil it's tainted
okay
what would happen if we did that well
needless to say oil prices would jump
likely to over 150 a barrel even higher
prices for you but then if that boycott
spread and moral boycotts tend to and
europe joined it buckle your belt we
talked to someone in the energy business
this morning energy traders to get a
little perspective on this he said a
total boycott of russian energy would
cause quote an absolute global disaster
that means recession depression
uncontrollable inflation and the rest
economic devastation to us and our
allies
and at that point in fact we're already
there we'd be forced to make up the
difference by getting more oil from
other countries because we need the
energy
batteries aren't going to supply it so
what would those countries be well let's
see they would be pretty clear saudi
arabia iran venezuela
to repeat
in order to wage a moral boycott we
become more dependent on saudi arabia
governed by sharia law iran a rogue
state and maduro's venezuela because
this is a moral statement we're making
this is a moral victory so feel good
about it as you go bankrupt that's the
short-term picture the long-term picture
of war with russia is even scarier than
that thanks to biden's policies russia
and china now form a block against the
united states this was the nightmare
scenario now it's real just today the
chinese foreign minister described
vladimir putin as china's quote most
important strategic partner
so are we going to see a boycott of
chinese goods in the united states
they're making this war possible oh
don't bet on it that would be racist
but we should prepare to lose our
position as holder of the world's
reserve currency that is happening in
slow motion it's unmistakable
now the biden people seem to have no
idea this is going on or maybe they want
it to happen joe biden was up there at
the state of the union bragging about
how he took 30 points off the russian
ruble in a single day hooray good for us
but once we stop celebrating our win
the destruction of the russian economy
they deserve it you gotta wonder is
there a downside to this could it be a
pyrrhic victory let's see
these policies have driven russia
china india turkey and other countries
to accelerate their flight from the u.s
dollar now to be clear that's the
majority of the global economy
this may be the most reckless and
destructive thing any american president
has ever done to the united states
if the war in ukraine ended tomorrow we
would live with the consequences of that
loss of the us dollars the world's
reserve currency for the rest of our
lives
no one in washington is even
acknowledging this is happening
they're looking for more moral victories
to win
and the companies love it the woke
companies apple mastercard lots of other
american companies are taking victory
laps for their role in punishing russia
great punish russia we're not against
that
but you've got to wonder
you've just seen a handful of woke
corporations crash a country and
impoverished its citizens
indiscriminately now that country is
russia so most of us aren't even
thinking about the precedent it sets
we're fine with it it's russia who cares
but is it possible these same techniques
might be used someday against some place
or somebody that you care about
what if one morning you woke up and they
decided that you're vladimir putin and
you must be erased
could that happen don't think about it
you're probably not able to think about
it clearly right now even if you tried
why because there's a moral panic in
progress
for the record this is the third moral
panic we have had in the united states
of america in less than two years you
don't want to live in a country in which
moral panics break out regularly by the
way
moral panics diminish the people engage
in them
and hurt the people who don't
they're degrading
they're crazy they're the opposite of
what you want you want to live in a
country where wisdom and restraint and
rational behavior and decency determine
the outcomes not screaming
but we live in a country of moral panics
the first one began in may of 2020 with
the death of george floyd in minneapolis
that changed america completely the
second moral panic was kovid
you've lived through that so for nearly
two years the shouting has not ended
hysteria is now the official language of
public discourse in the united states
that's not good for anyone except those
benefiting from it who is benefiting
anyone who lies for a living
the liars have perfect cover ask
yourself
how much of what you first heard about
blm
and then about the coronavirus turned
out in the end to be true
how many of the first stories were true
not many
it was almost all lies
but you didn't know that at the time
because you were busy being yelled at if
you dared to point out that actually all
lives matter they denounced you as a
racist if you expressed concern about
vaccine mandates of course they called
you an anti-vaxxer
sound familiar the pattern never changes
hey maybe war with russia is not a good
idea for the united states say that out
loud sometime it's not an extreme
position most americans would agree with
you but you will immediately be
denounced as a tool of putin what is
this
it's name-calling as a means of social
control
the people in charge have decided their
primary job is to decide who you should
hate
in an environment like this everything
feels like propaganda and that's because
much of it is
on thursday we told you that russian
forces had bombed a nuclear reactor in
ukraine that seemed to be true
president zielenski of ukraine had said
it repeatedly
but it was not true no reactors were hit
an unnamed ukrainian official claimed
that radiation levels in the area had
risen that turned out to be untrue as
well in the words of mark nelson as a
nuclear energy analyst quote i'm afraid
to say this looks like a coordinated
effort to induce panic
of course
it was what we call disinformation and
it was designed to get you to support a
war against russia
now maybe you support a war against
russia anyway
but you should at least know that you're
being lied to and manipulated which you
are
watch this segment from good morning
america the other day
ukraine's mother's daughters teachers
politicians beauty queens now on the
front lines defending their country
under siege and there is anastasia lena
a former miss grand ukraine photos of
her on instagram in fatigues rifle in
hand underneath patriotic hashtags
miss ukraine with a rifle defending her
homeland is there anything more
inspiring than that
it'd be more inspiring if it was real it
wasn't it was fake miss ukraine was not
defending her homeland that wasn't a
rifle it was an airsoft gun
so the whole thing was not a news story
though you read it as such it was a
propaganda shoot it was meant to deceive
you it was meant to make you want war
with russia sympathize with one side
over the other
it works that's why they do it
it's why the tech companies have
censored so many news sites recently
including from russia but not
exclusively from russia now we're
supposed to think this is a victory over
putin or something
but a victory for what
less information fewer perspectives
if getting to the truth was the point of
the exercise we as american citizens
would be able to read whatever we wanted
to read that was the rule for centuries
in this country it no longer is because
truth is no longer the point
instead twitter and facebook are proudly
censoring any information that might
quote undermine trust in the ukrainian
government really
since when are we required to trust the
ukrainian government or any government
don't ask
by the way over the weekend because
everything in america is unintentionally
hilarious now the new york times
attacked vladimir putin for censorship
turns out he engages in censorship tries
to control what his people can read
lost
in the relentless focus on war in
ukraine by the way is any perspective
about the world or war which is always
lacking in dc but never more so than now
the fighting in ukraine is terrible of
course you're seeing it happen
no decent person could fail to be moved
by the images but it's not unique
it's not the only war in recent memory
or even currently in progress right now
many thousands died in the 2020
nagorno-karabakh war that was between
azerbaijan and armenia ever heard of it
it ended less than a year and a half ago
no coverage there's been a gruesome war
underway in ethiopia for a couple of
years now it's again in progress as we
speak tens of thousands women have been
raped by militiamen many of them
intentionally infected with aids can it
get worse than that
how many people have died in the war in
ethiopia we don't really know
because no one in our media cares enough
to keep track it's just ethiopia
we do know that hundreds of thousands of
people mostly civilians have died in the
war in yemen it's where the bite
administration has continued to fund
doesn't get a lot of attention it's just
yemen who cares
all human life
is equal
all of us are equal in the eyes of god
the death of someone in ukraine is
exactly equivalent to the death of
someone in yemen
in its importance period
but hardest of all to ignore though our
media have pulled it off and ignored it
is the civil war that's underway 100
yards from el paso texas right now
the mexican drug war that's what we call
it's likely killed more than a hundred
thousand people
in 2019 alone close to ten thousand
mexican citizens just disappeared most
of them young men more journalists are
murdered in mexico every year than in
any other country in the world
you're seeing pictures on your screen
right now with that war
they're horrifying we're keeping the bad
ones off the screen trust us they're
awful but it's not a crisis it's totally
normal says the bud administration open
the southern border the border we care
about is ukraine's
now republicans in washington to their
eternal shame
have no problem with any of this in fact
many of them are more for war with
russia than joe biden seems to be
that is a disgrace
it will hurt them in the midterms it
will hurt them on some deeper level
because it does not serve the interests
of this country a war fought on behalf
of democracy that ignores the will of
the country fighting it
at some point so we'll explain exactly
what's going on here we're out of time
for tonight but it's enough to know
republicans are not representing their
voters
when they move to a position
that's
way more war-like than joe biden's when
they embrace the lunacy that could
really hurt this country they're not
representing people like bryce mitchell
bryce mitchell seems like a republican
voter he's a 27 year old mixed martial
arts fighter he's a cattle farmer from
cabot arkansas the other day someone
asked him what he thought about ukraine
at a press event
here's what he said
i just wanted to get your thoughts on
the whole russia and ukraine situation
you know
here's my first thought is i'm not going
nowhere to fight none of these wars for
these politicians i'm staying at home
and when the war comes to arkansas i
will dig my boots in the ground and i
will die for everything i love and i
will not retreat if this country is
invaded and everybody's saying well we
gotta we gotta evacuate we gotta leave
we go i will not i will dig my boots in
the arkansas soil and i will fight for
the people that i love for the land that
i love and the way life that i love but
i'm not going overseas to fight i don't
know what's going on to be honest
brother i really don't there's so much
stuff and i don't think nobody knows
what's going on fully there's been so
much political corruption in that area
you got biden and his son making a ton
of money
off of uh and using our tax dollars to
bribe
their people that's treasonous in my
opinion uh so you got hunter biden and
his son using our tax dollars hey if if
ukrainian government if you don't do
this we're taking your tax dollars he
shouldn't be giving our tax dollars to
that country anyways we got veterans out
here sleeping on the street and you're
going to give our freaking tax dollars
to these ukrainians and all i'd rather i
don't know what's going on over there
but i'm not going over there fighting
tell us how he's a putin stooge lindsey
graham and david frum and ann applebaum
liz cheney tell us how he's immoral
when the war comes to arkansas he said i
will dig my boots into the ground and i
will die for everything i love
that's the american position fight to
the death to defend what you love
your people your family your country to
defend it that's what we call it the
defense department it is not called the
department of nation building or the
bureau of trans evangelism
bryce mitchell may not have good grammar
but he understands exactly what's going
on here even people who claim to
represent him and our country have no
idea hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else